running battles in the streets of the
Lebanese capital for the second
consecutive night anti-riot police using
tear gas to disperse protesters who as
you can see are out in force anger is
growing frustration is growing in
Lebanon it is now the fourth month since
a anti-establishment protest movement
began people took to the streets to
demand a change in leadership the
country's economy has a near collapse in
close close to us here where our banks
people vandalizing banks are destroying
cash machines really venting their anger
at the banking sector banks exposed
informal capital controls prevented
people from accessing their deposits
savings there is a cap on the withdrawal
of brothers there's a cop in the
withdrawal of Lebanese pounds you can
see tear gas is being used by the
anti-riot police earlier today
protesters were outside a police badge
design
very tense this country is without a
government there's a political vacuum
since the end of October people are
demanding a government that will and
instead what what the politicians have
been doing is bickering amongst
themselves overseas in the United
Nations is warning that the situation is
quote dangerous dangerous chaos in
Lebanon and blaming really the
politicians for a failing financial
system